merci bien je vais parler un petit peu
je vous parlais de cinéma séries quand
on a sur une autre chaîne
la chaîne numéro trois avant de pas la
citer une émission vers veilleuse qui
s'appelle le cinéma de minuit je sais
pas si vous êtes comme moi si vous êtes
des téléspectateurs assidus v remarquer
que le mec qui présente le cinéma de
minuit
il a une voix d'une virilité absolument
merveilleuse alors tu as donné envie
d'écrire en un sketch une voie qu'il en
à peu près ça mais la demoiselle
messieurs ce soir dans le cadre du
cinéma de minuit
nous allons vous proposer un film tourné
en 1981 2 c'est un jeune qui s'intitule
nuit de noces avec dans le rôle de la
bouteille de champagne posé sur le
guéridon de la chambre nuptiale paul
préboist pouces explose je puis piven
vieux mage six bouteilles de champagne
regard j'ai débuté j'appuie le pape
c'est le bouche à ilham febrer chez
seller da et oui je sais je suis brut
c'est parce qu'on m'a frappé quand
j'étais petit chavagne me marre et le
maryland a vu déjà trois coups pu mettre
en scène drôle d'état pour obstacle tac
tac dans le rôle de la tapisserie cloué
au mur en face du lit de la chambre
nuptiale léon zitrone lyonnais mais
c'est bon ce jeu c'est effectivement en
frise du livre le chevreuil le ciel lui
je suis je peux voir le merisier kazakh
gauzy tatchoum qui se précipitent là
berrier kazakh transparente aux cerises
et ils sont tout à la casse est
merveilleux il n'y aura pas photo mais
so do pour départager les deux
concurrents messi
dans le rôle du futur amant de la mariée
jean-paul d'helmand de pétole et oui
c'est moi j'étais dans l'armoire déjà au
lit jamais trop prévoyant jeu navrant
des mois un service à réchauffer la loi
quant à moi le temps de visiter
l'afrique de faire un pôle terre avec le
pape de faire un double saut périlleux
entre l' empire state building et la
statue de la liberté dans deux en poupe
et d'amour je suis atouts importants
menés ou septième ciel nous non ne me
raccompagner pas jusqu'à la porte je
perds à la neige par la chasse tôt dans
le rôle de la femme de chambre pagnol
qui fait le ménage dans la chambre
nuptiale josé garcimore nous allons
lâcher comme dressé j'ai lu cont lâcher
parce que chez un couple normal
la dernière fois c'était à mandali les
puissants marie et le matin le mari de
mandali ils étaient pas contents et
grillé aïe aïe aïe c'est comme en chine
et m'a épousé une ombre
dans le rôle du matelas du lit de la son
rôle initial
jacques fabbri aaaah ça me koussa de ce
que nous sommes ce bruit santiago ça
s'arrête ça te pousse à le coup ça
reparte un repas ça s'arrête c'est
normal je suis en intérim et la multi
spire avec lequel on peut faire l'amour
à sa façon la réveiller dans le bourg de
la glace de la salle de bain aldo
maccione et jésus la glace
la glace de la salle de bains
naturellement comme ça qu'on arrive à se
déshabiller je vais voir les petits
corps je vais voir les petites choses
c'est la classe je vais voir les petits
slips la classe je vais aller commander
chez drucker les machins qui soutiennent
des dictionnaires les soutiennent
georges pourrait petit robert la que
celle moi je peux pas mettre les mains
sinon la cas dans le rôle dans le rôle
de l'actuel situé à côté du cru sont sur
la table qui va servir aux ablutions
intime de la mariée michel galabru ben
écoutez trop chaud nous ne sommes pas du
même monde moi je suis une cuvette en de
fayence l'espagnol oui et en rouge le
temps vulgaire que chevron ferrari et je
ne tolère plus que vous vous répondiez
dans moi alors sans être vulgaire
cruchot vous me bassinez pas des bandes
à mener dans le rôle de l'enfant qui est
né de cette nuit de noce moi même
comment voulez vous que je parle
correctement avec un père qui baisent si
mal
à